[Musique]
bonjour jean françois bour torse bonjour
merci de venir jusqu'à nous vous êtes
écrivain journaliste éditorialiste
ancien éditeur d'anna politkovskaïa et
vous publié aujourd'hui poutine la
logique de la force on va voir la
couverture de l'image apparaître en 2016
françois motors vous parlant de vladimir
poutine vous écriviez dans un autre
livre et je vais vous citer et comment
sortir du choix impossible entre la
soumission à la vision du monde qu'il
fout là des meilleures poutines
véhicules et une confrontation de plus
en plus tendue au bord du gouffre d'une
nouvelle guerre mondiale qui promet
d'être effroyable six ans plus tard vous
dites que le message que vous vouliez
faire passer à l'époque n'a pas été
entendu pour quelles raisons écoutez on
était plusieurs vous avez dit que
j'étais l'éditeur d'anna politkovskaïa
se trouve que ça fait juste 20 ans elle
était en train d'écrire ce livre qui
s'appelait qui s'est appelée de chenil
des zones russe où elle racontait les
horreurs de la guerre de la guerre
qu'ils étaient menés par poutine en
tchétchénie et elle disait que ses
méthodes ne
pouvait que contaminer la russie
qu'aboutir à une forme de gangrène qui
finirait par nous dénier tous et que
nous serions tous menacés on a publié
avec galets ackermans se livrer ces
niveaux d'un aboli kourskaïa n'a été
assassiné en 2006
et
personne n'a rien fait en réalité pour
arrêter ce qui se faisait déjà
en tchétchénie l'école filtration
c'était en tchétchénie on vous avait
parlé à un moment donné de l'acheter et
d'inconscience par rapport à ce qu'il se
passait oui je pense que les occidentaux
ne voulaient pas voir ne voulaient pas
croire
parce qu'il pensait que pour une bonne
part les tl les dirigeants qu'on sait en
france en particulier où il ya une
longue tradition d'amitié franco russes
ont pour ça qu'il fallait s'entendre
avec avec l'adie mire poutine que cet
homme était capable de mettre de l'ordre
et ça nous français ça nous arrangeait
aussi parce que il ya eu les attentats
contre le
dieu du 11-septembre et poutine s'est
tout de suite présenté comme un allié
pour lutter contre le terrorisme et on
s'est dit bon faisons affaire avec lui
donc on a pas qu'on a pensé qu'on
pouvait traiter avec lui tirer avantage
des liens avec lui sans comprendre la
nature profonde de son régime et cette
nature anna politovskaïa le disait
c'était une nature criminelle il y a
jean françois botton un débat parmi les
des observateurs des commentateurs et la
question pour eux est simple est-ce que
c'est vladimir poutine qui gouvernent là
aussi depuis 20 ans ou bien est ce que c
est vladimir poutine c'est une création
finalement delà de la russie est ce
qu'il ne fait pas en train de faire ce
que lui demande son pays qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
d'abord je crois que c'est quand même
vladimir poutine qui gouverne c'est je
sais bien que
comme le disait michel foucault le le
pouvoir et est l'expression au fond
d'une société
mais c'est quand même la lumière coutume
qui gouverne et au moins ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que il ya une
tradition
de brutalité de violence en russie de
violence politique que
depuis
les débuts de l'union soviétique quand
lénine a décidé de
créer les camps des solovki qui seront
le prototype du goulag
il a tout de suite
cédé à la paire le maintien de l'ordre
dans les camps parce que les bonnes gic
n'avait pas les moyens de
tenir les camps se disent avait d'autres
choses à faire est en fait il ya une
alliance profonde qui s'est installé
entre le pouvoir et le crime et le monde
du crime on l'entend dans le vocabulaire
des des dirigeants russes enfin quand
poutine
des 99 parle d'aller buter les
terroristes jusque dans les chiottes il
emploie le langage de la paix
quand il parle de l'ukraine il emploie
le langage de la paix lavrov en poids le
langage de la pelle c'est yves amand a
fait un très bon papier dans le monde là
dessus pour dire il ya des liens
intrinsèques entre le pouvoir et entre
ce monde criminel
jean-françois motors cette logique de la
force à laquelle vous faites référence
de quoi est elle le nom de quoi
procède-t-elle ou est ce qu'elle trouve
ses origines ses sources
première chose d'abord d'ordre quand
comme poutine s'est présenté à
l'élection présidentielle en 2000 ce
qu'il était
président par intérim il a fait un livre
de propagande se présenter un livre
d'entretiens dans lequel il tenait
absolument à raconter ce qu'il était
quand il était gamin il a raconté qu'il
était un voyou
dans l'est dans les rues de leningrad
après dans les mines graves détruites
après le siège de leningrad et qu'il a
appris la queue pour vivre il fallait
taper le premier
et c'est ça qui l'a vendu
au peuple russe qui sortait d'une
période très compliquée de la chute du
communisme et de la libéralisation
accélérée qui avait provoqué un grand
approfondissement de la population de
grands désordres j'ai dit tout à l'heure
que la pègre avait joué un grand rôle
elle a joué un grand rôle aussi dans le
processus de privatisation
il ya des des entreprises qui ont été
conquises au bout du de la kalachnikov
dans sa serre dans un certain nombre de
régions de russie je suis allé à il
ekaterinbourg l'ancien sverdlovsk j'ai
visité le cimetière d'ekaterinbourg
fallait voir les tombes des grands
mafieux on s'était des monuments
extraordinaire et c'est ces gens là qui
régnait d'une certaine manière et donc
donc donc si on vous suit bien au delà
des murs poutine et le régime
finalement le seul langage qu'ils le
sachent parler le langage de la force de
la de la totalité de la de la violence
c'est celui-là c'est dès le début de son
de son
premier mandat il a installé ce qu'il a
voulu appeler la verticale du pouvoir
terre qui voulait que tout se ramène que
tout se ramène à lui est que tout soit
décidé au kremlin là on peut comprendre
pourquoi il ya une grande tradition
russe est compris dans la littérature
notamment kangol écrit le réviseur et
racontent ces gens qui en sibérie mais
leur vie comme ils veulent et quand
c'est la panique quand arrive le revizor
c'est quelqu'un qui vient contrôler
enfin il y avait une espèce de tradition
de bordel d'autonomie etc et qui faisait
que la russie est un pays ingouvernable
donc c'est la proposition qui fait s'est
il faut gouverner le pays par la force
on va tout contrôle et essais les
organes c'est l'ex kgb le fsb qui va
contrôler tout qui va être le maître de
tous la guerre en ukraine aujourd'hui
jean-françois beau temps sur le terrain
l'ukraine est en plein élan si l'on si
l'on peut dire certains trépigne cet
appel même s'il ne parle pas de deux
victoires qu'est ce que vous pensez des
nouvelles du front alors première chose
c'est que indéniablement il ya un
tournant qui s'est produit
dans le fait que
l'ukraine a maintenant l'initiative ce
qui est un changement considérable
jusqu'à présent c'étaient les russes qui
menaient le bal
les occidentaux courait derrière
l'ukraine essayé de résister alors il
s'est sans doute passé un moment très
important
vous vous souvenez des combats très rude
qui ont lieu autour de severodonezk
qui s'enlève qui a été une bataille
perdue mais on s'est demandé pourquoi
zelensky ne demandait pas à ses troupes
de se replier de 20 30 km derrière un
fleuve ou une rivière pour être en
meilleure position pour résister et
contre l'avis sans doute de ses
conseillers militaires il a souhaité que
le combat soit mené jusqu'au bout a
scellé redonner ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé
on a tous été frappés par le déluge de
bombes qui tombaient et les russes ont
fait vraiment ce qu'on a pour appeler à
la même d'amérique n2 carpet bombing ils
ont à un tapis de bombes quoi la raison
ils ont fait un tapis de bombes cela dit
il on comment dire dépenser leur capital
et en termes d'armement en termes
logistiques au moment où l'armement
moderne qui étaient livrées par les
occidentaux par les américains en
particulier le hamas mais aussi les
français les canons caesar ont permis de
toucher les noeuds logistique et sont en
train de faire la différence alors
justement est ce que on a longtemps
présenté vladimir poutine et comme étant
quelqu'un qui reconstituait
calmement les armées russes finalement
est-ce que cette idée n'était pas
survendu quand on voit ce qui est en
train de se dérouler sur le terrain
elles étaient survendus il a peut-être
été survendu à poutine lui-même d'une
certaine façon alors la raison pour
laquelle on en est là c'est aussi parce
qu' une des choses sur lesquelles
l'union soviétique avait vécu pendant
longtemps parce que le système
d'économie d'état ne marchait pas
c'était le trafic la corruption mais la
corruption généralisée palapa la grande
corruption
j'ai un truc j'ai besoin d'un truc tu
mon offre un autre etc c'est des
habitudes très profonde et très très
probablement
dans l'armée ça a continué vous savez
poutine a mis en fait mettre en prison
un centre d'agents du fsb qui aurait dû
pendant au début de la guerre organiser
l'accueil avec des fleurs des des
troupes des troupes russes en ukraine il
avait beaucoup d'argent parce qu'ils ont
vu sur plusieurs millions de dollars
semble-t-il or ils n'ont pas fait et
sans l'outil que c'est parce qu'ils sont
me sens dans la poche jean-françois
motor cède hier à un moment donné devra
s'arrêter quoi qu'il arrive qu est ce
que vous voyez comment est ce que vous
voyez la russie d'après finalement
comment est-ce qu'elle sort de deux ça
alors d'abord la question de savoir
quand est ce que la guerre va s'arrêter
et c'est ni vous ni moi ne pouvons le
dire aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle va
encore être être longue parce que tant
qu'il n'y a pas de changement de régime
à moscou
poutine n'est pas en situation en état
dans l'état d'esprit de quelqu'un qui
pense qu'il doit maintenant négocier il
le contraire aider sur le recul et
négocier maintenant c'est reconnaître sa
défaite il n'a pas envie moi je pense
que le régime finira par tomber
sauf qu'on ne sait pas qui va le
remplacer
mais dans l'exposé moi dedans dans
l'histoire soviétique là aussi il faut
se rappeler que à plusieurs reprises il
ya eu des coups des coups d'état beria
est démis et est assassiné par par un
groupe de dirigeants dirigée par joe
coffe le chef de l'armée ou chauffer
déposée pour être remplacé par brejnev
gorbatchev lui-même a vécu un coup
d'état donc on peut tout à fait imaginer
qu'à l'intérieur du poids russe à un
moment donné des gens disent c'est plus
possible et il faut se débarrasser de
poutine un mot rapidement de ce sommet
de l'osce et s vadimir poutine aux côtés
des brahim raïs iranien aux côtés du
président chinois xi jinping est ce que
de ce point de vue là là là aussi peut
se trouver des alliés de soutien
je trouve que les images qu'on a vu hier
était extrêmement parlante on a
l'habitude de voir poutine extrêmement
fringant dynamique etc et face à jean
ping on voyait bien que ce n'était pas
lui le maître le même s'il fait dire à
certains que vladimir poutine est en
train de finalement de jeter dans dans
les bras du diable en coûter d'abord il
ya une cité de longue date entre entre
la chine et la russie
c'est pas nouveau et ça va continuer
d'autre part la partie asiatique de la
russie en sibérie c'est une partie vide
que la chine rêve d'occuper au moins
commercialement donc épis et il n'a rien
à offrir a saisi il dépend aussi jean
ping en termes d'armement de soutien
était alors qu'il est venu quémander du
soutien après il a l'air plus fort par
un quand ils voient raïs il a l'air plus
fringant mais parce que haïti a besoin
de lui mais vous savez poutine s'est
encore une fois c'est quelqu'un qui a
une pensée de caïds et dans la mafia ou
vous êtes dominant vous êtes dominé et
on voyait bien qu'ils étaient dominés
merci beaucoup jean françois boutin
d'être venu jusqu'à l'os est invitée de
de paris direct poutine la logique de la
force merci beaucoup les stars dont les
formations continues sur mon chéri
[Musique]